hier on a une énorme révélation c'était
en fin d'émission francesca m'avait
appelé ce week end
il m'a fait cette terrible révélation
elle est amoureuse en secret et là j'ai
envie de citer amour secret manuela
lopez obligé de se cacher amour secret
pas besoin de le dire
voilà tu connais manuela lopez vous
connaissez bien sûr je vois qu'on a les
mêmes références ça me fait très peur
regarder un petit récapitulatif ce que
j'ai reçu là je regarde leur ip c'est
nul mais je bave n'ont cessé m alors il
sait le mal au travail vous francesca
vous bas j'y réponds ce cas est vraiment
amoureuse elle m'a dit de le dire ce que
je n'aime pas c'est qu'il croit qu'il
est ou alors c'est nous je vous dis
c'est terrible c'est mathieu noms et les
gens voient pas comment il est en fait
moi je sais comment il est il est ultra
sensible et on ne peut pas ne pas
l'aimer parce que le mec il est drôle à
chaque fois qu'ils parlent d'amour
intelligent et il est magnifique mais
posé plusieurs fois la question savoir
s'il avait déjà été avec des filles et
madrid le 10 donc j'ai un très douce
[Applaudissements]
ce soir francesca francesca est une
chanson pour mathieu si mathieu nous
regarde
francesca c'est à vous
[Musique]
j'aurais pu te dire tout ça
ailleurs que chez eux on a
j'espère tu vas pas fuir
et pas non plus vomir mais en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que j'adore ton
sourire
[Musique]
lorsqu'il dit le soir
comme ça
non
j'espère qu'à la télé
tu me vois
même si tu as mal aux yeux
ça serait bien de se voeux
pour tout faire une lettre et dîner sous
la couette mais aussi sur toi ya plein
d'histoires
on dit que jamais
tu laisses tes pourquoi
c'est pas grave
je te lis quand même
[Musique]
je garde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]